about ideas about uh uh new projects and
thoughts you have as Young Generation uh
for our European Union I'm very happy to
see here participants of the eye event
our idea boosters uh we have also guests
uh from The Young Generation here
students from the Aran University we
have a lot of people representatives
from youth organizations thank you for
being here and taking the time to
discuss with us uh welcome to the
European youth hearing which is the
follow-up event to the excellent 2023
edition of the European Youth Event we
are uh um upholding all uh two every two
years the flagship action of the
European Parliament allowing to engage
with thousands of young people
discussing and debating on their ideas
and concerns about the EU and Beyond as
many of you might know following the uh
Youth Event in
2023 more than thousand ideas for
Europe's future were collected by young
people on youth ideas
eu. uh the 15 most popular ones have
been now compiled uh in the youth ideas
report shared with all members of the
parliament at today's hearing the top
voted ideas from the I 2023 will be
brought forward and will be discussed
here directly with the active
participations of members of the
European Parliament in such a way the
European youth hearing is a key
opportunity for young people to discuss
their concerns with European policy
makers ahead of the 2024 European
elections and for members to highlight
the legislative work already undertaken
in these areas this should allow us to
get closer to young voters reinforcing
parliament's Democratic legitimacy and
the ways in which it affects citizens
daily lives this hearing will start with
a short presentation of the 10 I idea
booster and young people will present
the 10 most popular ideas which also are
their concerns as young voters in the
runup to the 2024 European election uh
then the ideas will be debated into
detail with members of the European
Parliament and following this hearing in
the afternoon the young people present
present here will facilitate workshops
on each idea to develop their projects
by discussing with experts from EU
institutions representatives from youth
organizations and even members to
further develop their initiatives but
now I would like to give the floor first
to the 10 idea boosters who will present
the 10 most popular ideas from the I
2023 and I would uh please ask you to
introduce yourself and give us a short
overview of the ideas you present uh
that is the name the country they are
coming from uh where they live in the
idea uh that you will present so give us
a short introduction at the beginning um
and uh now uh I give the floor I'm
honored to give the floor
to yeah to the idea boosters please
start thank you so much
names uh my name is ingrit I'm from
Estonia and I'm here to represent the
idea that every trainee ship should be
paid or
funded hello I'm Fresco and I'm From
Italy and I uh represent the idea to
establish a common foreign policy
hi I'm Marta I'm from Poland and my idea
is don't include any country from Rasmus
plus
program thank you very much uh for this
uh short presentation of the main ideas
uh and now I'm honored to give the floor
to president metsola for her welcome
speech please Roberta you have the floor
thank you so much uh Sabina thank you
dear chair dear colleagues dear
participants and friends dear Young
Europeans and idea boosters welcome or
should I say welcome back uh to the
European Parliament it is truly a
pleasure to be part of this uh opening
uh session of the European youth hearing
an event uh which follows the 2023 I or
european Youth Event where I witnessed
firsthand uh the engagement all of all
of you and all the young people who are
present in contributing to a better
safer and stronger Europe for all as
we've also just heard following this
year's I over 1,000 uh impressive ideas
were collected from young people across
the continent and the 15 most popular
ideas are now uh gathered together in
the youth uh ideas report but to be
clear this is not just a compilation of
ideas where we put them in one document
and wait for the next event event it
this is a result of a collective effort
a journey that is filled with intense
exchanges with discussions and
activities that took place at the ey it
represents your dreams your aspirations
of a generation of Europeans that is
actively shaping the future of Europe so
this youth uh ideas report covers a wide
range uh of topics from sustainability
initiatives to educational opportunities
as as we've just heard and the digital
transformation of our society and I know
that some of these ideas are already
being rolled out and put uh into place
um by youth organizations across Europe
and I very much want to commend you uh
for that now when we look and when you
see this event today uh what would be uh
the ideal outcome uh so to speak we
would see it as a
platform for Meaningful dialogue and
collaboration between young people and
your elected representatives uh this is
the next step in uh bringing such top
voted ideas directly to your members uh
of the European Parliament uh it is an
opportunity to discuss your concerns
with European policy makers while also
um listening to members as they uh
discuss their legislative work um Sabina
is our expert on that in how to connect
uh with young with young voters now
every day we get closer and closer uh to
the 2024 European elections uh and with
every new geopolitical development we
are again reminded how important how
decisive the outcome of such elections
will be because the results of these
elections will determine the path that
we will take and they will shape the
decisions taken on the European level
for the next five years in fact when you
will speak to the colleagues I mentioned
Sabina but I we also have dragos pisaro
here as chair of the emple committee
employment and social Affairs committee
this is a discussion we have every day
so this is a defining time uh in your
lives especially uh for those of you who
have not voted before even more also in
those countries who have lowered their
voting age to 16 uh so young people's
voices reflect the evolving needs uh of
society and that is why it is important
to listen it is important to pass on the
message it is important to be clear and
to recognize that each and every single
vote matters so I would very much
encourage you uh to take away from here
from your experience after the the ey
after this event after meeting your
members after making new friends new
colleagues new lifelong um uh colleagues
I would say that's how I started my uh
my youth activism by meetings such as
this including some also uh in this room
uh in order uh to find your voice
whether offline or online and
participating in the election campaign
and making your voice heard now two
concluding appe first of all the youth
at the ideas report and the European
youth hearing are not just symbolic
gestures they are powerful tools for
shaping the policies and actions that
will Define our future we need you to
keep up uh your engagement besides
voting as I just said be more than that
do more criticize ask Express doubt and
make your position heard and secondly uh
here is the appeal to to colleagues um
who are sitting up here uh let's listen
to these ideas and take them on board uh
this is where we can put them in our
campaign manifestos when we are going to
go from City to City from Village to
Village as we uh go closer to uh the
election uh this is where the Front
Runners of change are and that is what
we need to take with us and that is what
we hope you take away from here so thank
you very much and enjoy and good luck in
the part in the discussions you have
thanks dear president mitsa dear Robata
thank you very much uh for this words
and uh I think it is very important that
you also showed that uh this uh hearing
is important for the president for the
uh Parliament as a whole and uh that we
really take the concerns the ideas the
interest of young people people really
serious in this house uh and that's not
just an alibi but but really something
that that works and that helps also to
give input to our everyday's work and
that shows also that we have uh so many
members at the moment present and some
more will follow uh during the hearing
uh thank you very much for being here
today
um now I would first like to give the
floor to Mrs ingred anido who will tell
us why all training ships should be paid
for or funded and to present uh a more
in more detailed form her
idea thank you very much dear chair uh
dear president honorable members as well
as my fellow young people thank you for
being here
today as we all know every single year
young people finish their studies and
Embark upon their professional lives and
just like that every single year with in
action towards exploitative labor
practices young people fall into the
same same trap of unpaid trainee ships
it leaves young people us in a
precarious position in terms of our
right to equal opportunities and our
mental health as well as our finances
this is why so many young people across
our continent are calling for fair
compensation for all trainee ships and
also we cannot let employers take the
easy way out they can just say that
they'll scrap trainee ships for a lack
of funds this is why whether young
people decide to stay in their home
country whether they decide to go abroad
for a traine ship they must have access
to funds similar to Erasmus Plus that
ensure that their basic needs such as
food housing as well as insurance are
covered fully this funding must be all
accessible to all thank you very
much thank you very much and I would uh
like to turn to Mrs Mart gja uh who will
develop a bit further on why we should
not rule out any country from Erasmus
Plus thank you very much Mr chair Mr
President and members and all of you
young people here I'm really happy that
you are here today I would like to
address a significant issue plugging our
site in 21st century exclusion in
various fors social inclusions Health
inclusions transport inclusions and a
lot of more all barriers that prevent
individuals from reaching their full
potential as someone who comes from a
small village I have often experienced
unequal access to the education compared
to my peers from a large cities this
gaps in education opportunities were
Stark and it left me with a sense of
frustration I know that I'm not alone in
these experiences this is why I stand
before you today to emphasize how
important it is for all Europeans to
have equal opportunities for education
and development on behalf of all young
people I appeal for No Country to be
excluded from arasmus plus program since
1987 this program has opened the doors
to mobility and cooporation for over 12
Millions young participants is had made
the dream of international experiences
and educational opportunities a reality
for many in real we cannot allow access
to European programs to be subject of
decisions of politicians all young
people should have the same rights to
education regardless of the country in
which they live in thank you very much
dberto
thank you very much and last but not
least uh uh I would like uh to introduce
uh um thank you for introducing these
ideas and I will now open the debate
with members of the European Parliament
uh uh and me dagos pislaru I give the
floor also to you for two minutes to
argument why All traine Ships should be
paid or
funded thank you very much thear chair
it is truly uh an an amazing moment to
be here it's just a continuation of our
activity in the parliament there was the
conference on the future of Europe where
young people's voices were heard pay
decent traine ships we had the eye
conference pay this and traine ships and
then in the employment and social
Affairs committee we worked on you know
making that a reality and we have here
with us the rapporter and I'm sure that
she will tell her tell you about her
experience in that but what is in a
nutshell what we've delivered we have
adopted um an act of the European
Parliament calling the European
commission very very clear not for a
recommendation for a directive for
Quality train isues right now the road
is paved the European commission doesn't
have margin of maneuver they need to
come with that and we ask there you know
very clear things adequate compensation
we ask there for social protection we
need ask there for increased access to
traine ships for vulnerable young people
we ask for accessible workplaces uh and
we also ask ask there for Clear learning
objectives so that young people will
know exactly what is expected from them
so we we are aware of that because we
had a participatory process with the
European young Forum attending all
events including your representatives
and we have delivered our part in
pushing at an Institutional level for
this type of legislation we are ready in
the European Parliament to make that a
promise that is going to be fulfilled so
not just another yet another promise of
politicians and for that we would like
to thank you for advocating throughout
Europe and through your organizations
for for this thing which is important
and contential for improving the way
young people gain experience before
having stable stable employment so thank
you very much for that and I'm sure that
you will find the European Parliament an
ally in this endeavor thank
you
thank you very much dagos uh and as I
have to leave earlier a little bit
because of the time schedule of uh Roba
I will pass over to you now uh I just
wanted to let you speak in peace so uh
we are now going on here with uh moment
the next thank you very much it is uh
thank you so much uh uh dear Sabina
yeah okay so uh passing the roll right
now it's changing the head it is my very
uh uh my biggest big pleasure to invite
um Alicia Holmes gelle on behalf of snd
to take the floor
prina yeah thank you dragos and well I'm
really happy to be here in this room
full of of young people and going to the
point of of the paid internships for
those who doesn't know me I mean I'm
Alia HS I'm 30 years old and I'm MP and
not that long time ago I was suffering
this non not non-paid internships
situation that's why um since I engaged
the youth from my party back to 2012 I'm
a huge defender of of this of this cause
um and I want to say that thanks to our
political party uh we pushed a lot uh
since the last mandate I have Brando
here also this mandate um to ban the
unate internships uh actually we passed
five resolutions where the ban uh
was not passing because we didn't have
the the support uh but in the last uh
the last time in a non legislative file
uh we proposed for having a directive
that was not easy at all uh but we
achieve it and I'm happy to to tell it
to you because I was in the conference
on the future of Europe I have been in
many European youth events and is a
demand of you all and we need to deliver
to you so um I will be the reporter of
this directive uh we will start after
now they are in negotiations with the
social Partners uh and I hope that the
commission will deliver to this
Parliament soon the the the document and
that we will be able to introduce all
the points that you shared with us uh
that are the points of all of you and
which I really share with all of you so
uh I will do my best for this to to be
possible by political family will do uh
its best to make it possible and I hope
that you all will be will we have happy
with the results and that finally we
will end up with this uh situation that
is unfair because it's one of the first
steps uh in your way of life so I think
it's really important that there is no
frustration in it thank
you thank you thank you very much dear
Alicia and right now it's it's my
pleasure to invite Monica seedo on
behalf of Renew on the same topic please
Monica
now it works thank you very much chair
and uh thank you all the young Europeans
uh for their contribution and ideas this
is very important um a good fact or good
news is that 80% almost 80% of young
Europeans have uh done at least one uh
trainers ship the bad news uh almost or
more than half of them were
unpaid um but trainer ships they are
definitely uh they definitely facilitate
the access to the job market in the
future by 68% which is much and as the
reporter of the legislative initiative
report quality traine ships uh in the EU
I say clearly yes All traine Ships
should be paid or compensated and why
and uh this lies close to my heart
because in average uh a trainy ship in
the EU costs 1,000 euros and not
everyone can afford that especially the
less privileged so and therefore um it
is crucial that um training ships in the
EU are paid uh covering for example at
minimum uh and you mentioned it the cost
of living Necessities such such as
housing food Transportation but also
taking into account uh the cost of
living in each member state of course um
it is important we must guarantee equal
chances for
everyone and uh by quality training
ships I mean or we mean not only that
they are paid but uh that they are that
you have a real learning experience uh
uh you have good uh working conditions
which is important accessibility for
example for people with disabilities and
mentorship are important and these
points are also I also address uh in my
report and we need clear uh guidelines
and criteria for Quality training ships
so that's why I call again upon uh the
dear commissioner Schmid uh that we are
waiting for his let's legislative
proposal because there's not not much
time left until the end of term so uh
Dear Mr schnit uh the clock is ticking
uh and I would like to thank also the
European Youth Forum uh for the good uh
cooperation and thank you all for your
contributions we need you you are the
Next Generation Mercy thank you thank
you very
much is my pleasure right now to invite
on behalf of snd uh our dear colleague
honorable Hanes ha for his intervention
on don't rule out any country for
arasmus plus
please so thank you much uh thank you
very much chair and thank you very much
young young Europeans uh for this topic
because I think the most important
political uh issue is education or to
speak with a former British prime
minister about the three most important
it's education education education and
the Au often has brought s to
communicate about his success stories
and Erasmus Plus is one of these uh
topics where we could uh create a better
understanding of the European Union and
I'm a member of the cult committee which
is responsible for young people for
culture and education and because we
were fighting we here in this Parliament
were fighting for an increase of the
amount for arasmus plus it happened
because there were ideas of cutting
Erasmus Plus funding and so we were
successful and there are 28 billion EUR
for the Times between 21 and 20
2027 I was a uh author and co-author for
arasmus Plus for countries like
Switzerland and for uh the UK and uh we
agreed on that uh education is not
cherry picking it's very important for
understanding and we should give Unity
to all these these countries and uh it's
not a question uh of the ability of
taking uh part in the arasmus plus these
countries also have uh to stick to the
principles and to the rules of arasmus
plus so there was an open door and there
is an Open Door for the UK and as well
for Switzerland which is very happy to
participate but the countries and their
governments have to decide to be part of
it but uh European politics and
especially this house opens the doors
for Erasmus Plus and if there is the
question why uh Hungary um where in
Hungary are some uh uh fundings were
frozen then I have to say it is not
because Hungary is excluded as such but
it has to stick uh the rules and
principles and it's also a question of
transparency in the spending and in the
receiving uh of money and of course I
agree with you that it's not only about
every country that agrees to the
principle should have the opportunity to
take part arasmus plus is opportunity
and we should open it to all young
people and to groups that had not the
possibility to take place and it should
be an inclusive program and funding and
this is what we are working on and what
we want to make real and to to bring it
into uh reality thank you very much
thank you very
much
and let me then give the floor to our
honorable colleague Andrea bshar please
you have the
floor thank you very much for the floor
um
and I'm grateful to young people uh to
include uh the point this point uh in
the youth report and uh especially
addressing uh the cautionary case of the
Hungarian students uh as well uh in this
point uh as we all know that Erasmus
Plus program has long been celebrated as
a flag a flagship of international
cooperation and academic exchange
fostering understanding and diversity
and unity across European
borders and uh it served also as a tool
of diplomacy expanding relationships
Beyond geographical boundaries and
contribute to Mutual understanding and
in a word RI with division and conflict
uh the Rasmus plus program uh should be
an example of unity and collaboration
and I know that we all want it and
therefore it is very regrettable that
the European commission uh made young
people become victims of a political
disagreement uh between the European
Union and the government uh of a
particular member State and the case of
Hungarian students professors and
researchers I think is very unique
because they were punished uh unfairly
and
unjustly uh to add a very important
point the right to choose the
educational institution to learning is a
fundamental human right and every
student should have the right to choose
uh um and to participate in
international exchanges Mobility
programs like the Erasmus Plus just like
uh uh those students learning in in
state universities and differentiating
between students between Hungarian
students according to their choice of
universities uh is a big discrimination
so it is not only the loss of the
students but it's the loss of the
European Unity as well and I think it
it's very regrettable because excluding
countries can further exor barate
inequalities in Education and Research
it uh perpetuates uh the gap between
institutions and students destroys
already existed cooporation and creates
huge disadvantage so we have to work uh
uh on that that we have uh we can we can
get back uh to the uh point and to just
to make uh one more point I think uh in
the uh useth report there are some uh
misleading points because uh there's a
statement that Erasmus funds in Hungary
uh has never been the issue of concern
by any European institution and secondly
High ranking governmental officials left
the trust Boards of the uh European
Commission on uh the European uh
commission's concerns so I think uh to
be clear uh Hungary also wants to uh uh
solve the situation just like the the
European Union and as Hungarian students
as well thank you yeah thank you thank
you very much yeah yet you have a nice
sample of a debate in the European
Parliament um andan there are arguments
on both sides um this is a debate about
young people with young people for young
people so the final word goes to young
people so dear idea boosters would you
have anything to add and let me start
with you ingred please you have the
floor yes thank you so much uh thank you
so much for the responses and all of the
work that you're doing as well uh we we
need support we need the the ear of
decision makers of course to help this
come to a reality that young people are
no longer exploited for their labor and
uh there's always a tough balance
between having a quality uh internship
or traine ship because to be frank in a
lot of cases those are jobs they are
very frankly the responsibilities uh
that are given to young people are
equivalent to a job and then they are
masked in this kind of uh fake view of
uh a trainee ship or internship but in
reality uh it could very easily be a
entry-level position and by packaging it
as a trainee ship or internship or
learning opportunity whatever you call
it is just another way that uh young
people are being taken advantage of so
once again thank you very much for
listening to us for assisting us and I
really hope that uh maybe not this class
that's going to graduate uh in the
coming spring but the one after that we
actually have the Protections in order
to have uh paid trainee ships and
internships for all thank you and thank
you very
[Applause]
much Martha your
turn yeah I would like to thank you for
for your opinions and for your support
and for your views on the topic and I
know that all of us young people here
are really really happy to have you here
and to the fact that you understand our
problems and you want to listen and you
want to be here and just uh spend your
time here with us it's really important
and it's really important to for me
especially because uh I really feel that
it's the thing that we are doing are
important so i' would like to thank you
for for your time for thank you for your
opinions and thank you for all of you
your views and I hope that arasmus plus
program will be more developing and
every single student have the chance to
to visit different country live abroad
and have this amazing opportunity learn
languages and just be more educated and
more development than ever thank you
very much and thank you very much and
have a round of applause for our two
first idea boosters uh just to let you
know that languages are available due to
our amazing team of interpreters English
French German Italian Spanish and and
and polish so please use that uh if you
if you need it I um I'm right now um
finishing uh this first round and pass
the floor back to our dear chair Savina
fhen and a big thanks from all our
colleagues uh from the employment and
social Affairs committee and thank you
very much for having me at this event
thank you
[Applause]
so and I also would like to say thank
you to dragos for taking over and uh
replacing me in the in sharing this
meeting uh now we go on with the uh uh
second round I would now invite you to
uh the discussion on uh the set of ideas
which is more turned towards the EU as a
global player and I would also like to
ask you to excuse me for the 15 minutes
uh uh that I left uh was because we had
to meet uh the president uh with a group
of of young people uh from the uh youth
prizes of of chain uh so um I would now
like to give the floor to Mr Franchesco
dunell who will tell us how to be
stronger together establishing a common
foreign policy Franchesco the floor is
yours thank you Mr
chair we as Europeans stand more united
today than we've ever been in all of our
history nevertheless we're facing
challenges our fing fathers would never
have imagined we thought the wor on the
European soil would be a thing of the
past we were wrong some problems require
everybody to get together and act as one
one of those problems is foreign policy
we will be able to cut administrative
costs while also showing strength
through Unity on the world
stage Global events such as Co and the
war in Ukraine showed us why it's a must
for All European nations to stay and act
together sting won Churchill United with
stand divided with all supporting the
treaties reform in late November is a
good starting point but your work
honorable MEPS will not end there though
you are responsible today for our
tomorrow and the future Generations will
judge you accordingly thank you and slav
ukraini
thanks a lot Fran Franchesco for these
uh thought stimulating idea and I would
like to turn next to uh Mrs Cruz glinka
is that right um who will carry on with
another idea on Europe as a global
player explaining us why Europe should
be self-sufficient with raw materials
please the floor is your unknown only to
many critical raw minerals shaped the
foundation of our modern lives and they
remain crucial to the progress and
development of Technologies needed for
the digital and environmental
Transformations as we look towards the
future it's imperative we the youth
inform the policies shap in
tomorrow the EU needs to mitigate the
risk towards Supply chains related to
critical minimals ensuring current
strategic directions are fit for
long-term resilience Co 19
and the war in Ukraine have highlighted
the vulnerabilities of the EU investment
and Innovation are core to realizing the
critical raw minerals act however the
the needs for the eu's mustn't be uh the
needs for the eu's pro pro Prosperity
must be balanced against the commitment
to life and we mustn't enable suffering
in places such as the DRC the future of
the youth mustn't come at the expense of
Youth elsewhere
that through environmental degradation
and exploitation of
others so thank you very much and now
I'm
open I think it is a very important
input uh we got and now I would uh open
the floor for the discussions with the
MEPS and first I would give the floor to
M salima yanbu from Renu the floor is
yours for two minutes please
Sala
many thanks dear Sabine many thanks
everybody I'm delighted to be here as a
former teacher SP on my Fridays with
youngsters like you to work on these
topics and on this issues how to improve
Europe because this is the Europe that
we're working on and you will be the one
living in it and you're totally right
sir so foreign policy and common
security policy has been threatened by
the Lisbon treaty in 20 2009 we have
created
uh High representative for the union for
foreign policy and security policy in
the person of Joseph borell and we have
a set up a diplomatic diplomacy European
diplomacy service that we call sea but
the common adjective that is part of
this title when we are truthful and when
we look at the member states they have
an essential role in the definition of a
foreign policy of the European Union and
we also have the decision-making process
by unanimity of the European Council and
the EU Council that blocks all of this
so I'm totally in agreement with you you
totally right it is even more necessary
today to develop a common foreign policy
for a strong United Europe of course and
especially following the last events
that took place in the world that you
have mentioned and when we're faced with
the challenges that we have at the
moment so towards the geopolitical
Europe borell has declared that the
geopolitical awakeness of Europe was the
war in Ukraine at the last plenary and
also the need for Europe to speak in one
common voice to be listened to on the
international stage and it's true that
at the moment the hesitations as well as
the cacophony that was piered from the
outside regarding the war between Israel
and amas but also with the agreement
with Tunisia shows the weaknesses of
this uh foreign policy of Europe today
and the need to deal with a common
European uh foreign policy so I think
that's important to coordinate
internally and also to remind and
remember the positions taken and the
decisions taken uh lately these are unal
decisions but on the outside not
everybody knows how the European Union
Works everybody talks in the name of the
European Union I think that this is
something at stake in order for Europe
not to be decriminalized by sending some
contradictory messages it's important to
have one common unique message so your
intervention comes at the right time
this is the right time to talk about the
questions of the treaties we will have
to deal with this this is a key point on
that topic because if we do not change
the treaties we will carry on being
slowed down in our decision- making
process because of the unanimity Rule
and some decisions are way too important
to depend on the vetos from some member
states there is a commission this is
AFCO it works on this treaty and I think
that it's going in the right way and we
are working on this and your proposals
will feed our debates and in any case I
invite you to follow these debates I
think that this will be a real uh topic
to be debated at the next elections in
2024 and I'm certain that you will
participate in this fully many
thanks thank you very much I just would
like to remind also our colleagues to
stick like uh our young uh pres uh
presentations here to stick to the
speaking time a little bit more so uh
because uh the young people were really
uh wonderful in keeping their time uh I
also would beg the politicians to do so
thank you very much uh the next is MP
Muhammed khim it's right uh the
pronunciation good enough good enough
thank you very much uh I give you me a
couple of minutes extra I'm I I give you
the floor for two minutes on Europe
should be self-sufficient with raw
materials please the floor is yours
first of all I I missed your
name what was it Cruz Cruz I think uh
your contribution is very important I
mean I do think when it comes to
critical raw materials or the energy
transition we should not we should
rethink our relation with the rest of
the world but also we should rethink
what we want to have do we want
strategic Partnerships based on equality
or do we want colonialism 2.0 cuz I
don't don't think the world is waiting
for that so let me be very honest yes
long-term resilient Supply chains but
please long-term strategic Partnerships
with countries in Africa South America
Etc based on equality this is something
I would love uh to to develop and I can
assure you that the parliament's team
that's negotiating on the critical raw
materials act has that has that in the
core I don't want to bore everyone way
too much on this topic but I do want to
say if you have any ideas if you have
any comments related to critical raw
materials you know slide in the DMS of
politicians send an email to your
representative and I can assure you most
people sitting here listen and when we
get emails we read them we actually we
even answer so please inform us send us
you know bother us with knowledge with
ideas because we take decisions today
that will affect you tomorrow and will
affect the generation coming after you
tomorrow so make sure that not only come
to these events but keep on pushing when
it comes to this agenda when it comes to
a more equal world where we have access
to knowledge and Technology because both
will be essential for the green
transition and for critical raw
materials and I'll give you 20 seconds
back
chair thank you very much a very good
example on coming to the point in a
short time perfect thank you uh now I
give the floor to Hildegard Benta also
on the issue of uh should Europe be
self-sufficient with raw
materials yeah H thank you so much I
mean you have put a very provocative
thesis I would say should be
self-sufficient I mean we are long way
from being self-sufficient so because we
are highly
dependent and what we are now looking
for is to become a little bit less
dependent and also to share a little bit
the burden because currently the mining
has done in some countries but very
little in Europe so if we talk about a
just you know development then it's just
fair that we talk about mining in Europe
and here this concerns you because we
are talking about modern mining new
mining a mining which has which looks at
its environmental impacts and there are
many good jobs in mining maybe a lot of
us a lot of you have thought it's only
coal mining or so on it's dirty jobs but
these are Hightech jobs so I would and
we need young people who invest
themselves into these sectors because
what is it all about it is about zero
emission Technologies what do we talk
about why do we need so many critical
raw materials because we want to expand
renewable energies because we want to
you know uh uh start with hydrogen
production because we want efficient
Motors because we want electric vehicles
so this is your future these are the
Technologies you will live with because
we have to transform our Energy System
because we have to transform our
Mobility systems so this is why I think
we have to rethink you know mining and
we have to rethink our our needs but I
would say it concerns you because it has
also job
[Applause]
potential thank you very much much H
bener and I I would like to give the
floor back to our young idea boosters
and first I would like to give the floor
to Francesco gelli you have the floor
for one minute to repeat thank you Mr
chair uh I believe the right thing to
say right now is that Europe is based on
reaction not action we see what's
happening and then we decide what we're
going to do with it there's no vision
it's all it's it's always we're running
behind
problems uh this specific idea and the
reform of the treaties it's all about
what European Union you will leave us
you are now here today as Ms you have
the power to decide what's going to
happen so I'm looking forward to the
conference and seeing what you propose
and what is proposed by Europe on all
levels to change what's happening here
you know I read the 400 amendments that
the parliament has proposed to this
reform of the treaties it's very hardw
Waring in some places because you have
very very significant proposals taken in
place by MEPS and it's very very very
important that you follow through with
this thank
you thank you very much and for changing
the treaties we need the support of all
the citizens in Europe thank thank you
very much and now I give the floor to
Cruz glinka you also have uh the floor
for one minute to repeat on what you
have heard so thank you for your
contributions I wholeheartedly agree
that we need to be very careful that the
green transition doesn't become another
form of colonialism and that's a very
important point when you see some of the
pictures in places like the DRC with
kids mining is really disgusting frankly
and so it's important that we are very
conscious of how we're doing our
practices and then on the other point I
just want to add is when we look at how
we can get these resources
inside Europe we need to make sure that
we are protecting the environment
because many many communities where
we're looking at exploring mining aren't
very happy about the strategy so we need
to make sure that it's a consultative
process that integrates them into it
thank
you so I would like to say thank you for
this insightful discussion and
definitely there are many excellent
ideas that can be carried over into our
policy making and uh I think the
exchange should not be just today but
also in future on all these topics
because uh they are relevant not just
for for us here as policy makers but
especially for the Young Generation for
the future and now let's move to the
third set of ideas this time we will be
looking into ideas how to improve our
education
processes uh Mrs Seline coo will tell us
how teach more about the EU in schools
and to be honest that is something I was
I'm crying out loud each and every day
to do that so uh please tell us what are
your ideas to do that thank you chair
Dear honorable members of the parliament
uh I'm representing the idea of teaching
more about the in schools as stated in
the youth report less than 1% of the
population of under 18 years old in the
European Union comes across a topic at
school in their different levels of
education however even though there is
no common legal framework that enforces
countries to teach more about the UN in
schools EU institutions has increased
their visibility by doing simulation
games or teaching or having materials
that increase a knowledge regarding the
EU but why is important to teach more
about the EU it is important because it
is quite obvious that it affects young
people's everyday life and it
strengthened the sense of a common
European identity which will lead to
make European Union more self-reliant in
a long term after having the theoretical
approach having more visits and getting
a practical sense of how these entities
work will make young people people more
visible will make young people more
knowledgeable
of how European Union works and this
will make us to go towards a more
sustainable and inclusive future
together thank you very
[Applause]
much thank you very much and it's good
to for us as cult committee and many
members of cult committee to know that
we have uh such engaged young people on
our side because we are asking the
member States since years to do more in
this field and in each and every report
we do on education this is not missing
uh but we have to convince the member
states that the EU is important because
otherwise we will not come a step
forward so thank you very much and next
will be Mrs maril Rosanne vanon uh she
will tell us how to introduce
sustainability education in schools and
I think that's also especially for the
Young Generation a very important topic
please you have the
floor thank you m chair um well during
the European Youth Event a main idea was
the introduction of sustainability into
schools why do we care well there's a
high awareness among 15y olds of climate
change and the environmental crisis and
the need to address this moreover more
than half of young people has
experienced climate anxiety we know
climate change is a problem but data
shows that far fewer students feel a
sense of agency to make a real
difference now I and many other young
people with me argue for sustainability
education in schools
the youth in the EU wants the school
curriculum to emphasize Environmental
Protection they want to learn more about
climate change and what they can do in
the form of sustainable development
young people want to learn and want to
learn about what is needed to turn
climate change around give them this
opportunity by making these themes part
of the normal school
[Applause]
curriculum thank you very much for this
input and uh now I would like to uh turn
to our MEP Dominic Ru deesa he's raur on
the European parliament's report on
European citizenship education and will
speak on teach more about the EU in
schools please you have the floor
Dominic thank you thank you all thank
you to the youth who've
presenting these ideas I agree with
you as as the president has pointed out
we are already working on it we have
passed a report on some training
measures um at European level because
we acknowledge
that EU citizen need to bet train a bit
more on um the EU institutions and we
have proposed a couple of ideas a common
curriculum for European
Society so this
initiative is
about
teaching about the EU institutions and
that can be implemented by some member
states and uh we can work on it with the
European commission and we
also worked on a specific module on
education that would be included in all
programs financed by the EU and these
modules will focus on Erasmus
Plus on solidarity at EU level as well
on training that is funded by the social
program
so this
module will be part as I said of a
specific training and thanks to these
initiatives we'll
have a concrete impact
on how we teach about EU and we will
increase that
1% so this idea
was also discussed in the conference of
Europe and we addressed such uh training
in all member states so thank you very
much thank you very much Dominic and now
I will give the floor to m j abukari on
the same idea please Jo you have the
floor uh it's a it's a pleasure to to be
here and thank you very much it was a
pleasure to meet Mo many of you in in in
Strasburg and now a pleasure to to be
with you here um and I apologize that I
need to leave immediately after speaking
because we have the discussion on the
European disability card in the
employment committee starting right now
uh I will not go uh on on further
analysis of what dominic just said I I I
second everything that he that he said
but I think that this should go hand
inand with a broader discussion of what
we want for education for schools uh I
think schools need to be uh playing a
different role as we are as we have now
including uh to be fundamental safe
spaces for people where they can
actually be themselves and and have the
conditions to be themselves and have the
support to be themselves uh to focus on
nutrition for example and also to have a
strong strong engagement regarding
citizenship I think we need to
understand what is the role of us as
Citizens are we just consumers are we
just voters are we just uh electors uh
um uh people that participate in this in
this process or are we also active
citizens and I think this is something
that needs to be included in the
curricula all throughout uh uh all
throughout the educational system in in
Europe not only with the focus on what
is the reality and the functioning of
the European Union because it is
fundamental to create the awareness of
the importance of this institution but
also how to create and to build citizens
that are more actively engaged in the
transformation of their own communities
even on a local level so I think this is
fundamental
that we consider this strategy and this
proposal that you are bringing forward
of uh uh fostering the the the promotion
of Education uh and to include EU
curricula in school systems together
with a with a different view on what is
active citizenship and participation and
what is the role of school in all of
this thank you very
much thank you very much Joel and now uh
I come to the next next speaker from the
parliament is Marcos Roser and uh he
will tell us how he believes we can
introduce sustainability education in
schools please
maros
ran it's true that the climate crisis is
already here it's clear and it's going
to change our lives in the following
years and here in the parliament we're
we're working to create policies to to
create a more sustainable world that
will leave no one
behind but for this we need education as
you said and we need a trained um
citizenship that can deal with the
digital transformation and we can only
do that through the education
system strong resilient education
systems that are public and that can
offer a quality education for everyone
in 2023 we celebrated
the uh year of uh skills and it's a way
of progressing within Europe having
Education and Training as a
base and this education needs to be
linked to the Civic citizenship
education and also uh we need to take in
account the importance of the
Environmental
[Music]
Education we are working in this agenda
we want to create the European education
space in 2025 a more ambitious
space in this project we have worked
closely with other
initiatives because uh for
example um improving the sustainability
of our buildings uh doesn't have to
sacrifice the beauty of set
buildings
and one of the 15 ideas that have been
more voted within this projects is the
uh in this uh report has been uh the
sustainability
education so yeah we do support the
sustainability education in the future
thank
you thank you very much Marcos and now
we will ask our idea boosters uh if they
would like to answer please uh Selena
Kuma you have the floor thank you very
much
uh firstly I would like to thank you for
your interventions and your own opinions
because is as it was stated before
education is one of the most important
topics that we need to talk about and
actively act on it so teaching more
about the EU will make us more aware to
behave as active citizens citizens as we
will come across topics such as the rule
of law and strong democracies and
something additional that I would like
to add is that coming from Albania a
country that aspires to join the
European Union I'm really looking
forward for your actual and concrete
recommendations on how we need to work
on it and become more engaged on this
topic thank you very
much thank you very much and now I give
the floor to Mar rosan van hton for her
replies thank
you thank you for your input dear
members of parliament I am happy to hear
that there are so many sustainable
policies already in the EU and the EU
does have a leading role in these
practices I agree that with the new age
comes new skills and I'm happy that the
EU is focused on these new skills I
agree it is an important basis that
everyone needs access to everyone needs
uh the opportunity to have education on
sustainable practices and access to
these new new skills so that we have a
strong Workforce for the future I would
argue that we need this as quickly as
possible because as you said climate
change is already here so I really hope
that we will in the future as soon as
possible have strong education on
sustainability practices to also further
your policies thank
you thank you very much for yet another
very interesting and fruitful discussion
and uh for your input and now I would
invite our next idea boosters to take
the floor and talk about CL climate
change and
sustainability Mr Adan cosmin
Pop please you have the floor you will
talk about climate change is Wrecking
havoc on our health make it a priority
to change that yeah it's a pretty long
title right
yeah so we all know by now that the
burning of fossil fuels is the main
cause of climate change and air
pollution and data shows that air
pollution contributes to asthma and
allergies development and in turn
climate change aggravates the diseases
one in Europeans will suffer from an
allergy by 2025 and cases of Asma Rising
with large statistical differences
between countries showing the lack of
prevention and research in this area 98%
of Europeans are breathing highly
polluted air Eastern Europe and
Community poor communities being most
affected and air pollution kills
annually in Europe more than 400,000
people and half could be preventable by
imposing who guidelines with chronic
illness they are burden to our Public
Health Systems so to solve these
problems we should set Bolder deadlines
for the Clean Air package and bring
together patients doctors innovators and
entrepreneurs to accelerate patient
driven Solutions Implement guidelines on
National prevention campaigns and boost
research for a better understanding of
the current status of diseases
aggravated by climate change and also
boost boost investments in tele medicine
and other digital tools to better assess
the health status and development of
disease of these patients thank
you
thank you very much for raising this
very important topic and now I give the
floor to arnor Charles bar the floor is
yours to tell how to stop food waste
food waste in the EU helping the most
vulnerable and I think food waste is
something we are already dealing with
please you have the floor indeed thank
you Mrs uh chair um so as you all know
uh currently 33% of Al food in Europe is
uh either lost or wasted well at the
same time 20% of the European population
is at risk of poverty or social
exclusion while this is a big problem
it's also a big opportunity for us to
fight both food waste and hunger at the
same time to tackle this we will need
collaboration between governments
businesses and citizens we call on the
European Parliament to propose legally
binding targets that obligate shops and
businesses to donate all surplus food
before its expiration date to the hungry
and poor in France this is already the
case and it has already shown
significant impacts locally luckily
there are already countless
organizations and
initiatives um dedicated to address this
issue so let's shine light on these
initiatives and create a supportive
system where they can make their change
and that way we can solve our food waste
thank
[Applause]
you thank you very much and now would
open the floor again for another round
of MPS and first I have SAR Chas and you
have the floor for two minutes to talk
about climate change and health
thank you very much chair and uh I would
like to to congratulate of the idea
boosters and incredible proposals you
have put forward on the table and the
importance of accountability uh when we
decided and stated that uh climate
crisis was an emergency uh back in
November 2019 we were also basically
stating that this climate emergency is a
Health crisis because you mentioned many
of the issues related to climate change
and health but we need to be
consequential and we have done that
through the European uh Health report
for um 2021 2027 when we have an
approach with one health approach
meaning considering the environmental
the animals health and the human health
as intertwined but we also need more
multis sectorial approaches and we need
to be consequential with what we decide
here in this house and I'll give you an
example 10% of uh cases of cancer come
from pollution and we are here battling
and trying to increase our air quality
in the you hence reducing air pollution
we cannot go and ask for a a very um
competent very ambitious cancer plan
without addressing the causes of cancer
we cannot ask for uh a beating cancer
plan a very important proposal and then
vote against better air quality in
Europe that's what's happening at the
moment and accountability needs to be
done and have a priority when we come
into the next elections because we're
losing the velocity when it comes to
dealing with the climate crisis and
climate crisis is a Health
crisis thank you very much Sarah and now
i' would uh turn to Irena yva uh for two
minutes on the same topic climate change
and health uh and how to make it a
priority please you have the floor thank
you very much chair and of course thank
you also everyone else for um sharing
your ideas it was great hearing them and
also reading them uh I'm specifically
glad that you have chosen this
connection between the climate um change
and health as one of your priorities
because indeed you are right we already
heard from my colleague um climate
change is and will continue to greatly
affect our well-being our bodies our
health and consequently our quality of
of life and as you have rightly
mentioned climate change brings on
climate hazards um this summer actually
in my country uh Slovenia we had really
devastating floods uh there were regions
that were completely cut off from the
rest of the country no drinking water no
electricity and um you know it severely
affected also the health um of our
citizens so I know now even more first
hand um you know what this correlation
uh means um not only are the symptoms of
diseases worsen in the climate uh you
know hazards it's when diseases are born
uh so the fact is that all around Europe
climatic conditions are making the
emergence and transmission of climate
sensitive infectious diseases even more
prominent in in our continent um I'm
also glad that in the report you have
connected cancerogenic cancerogenic
chemical
um uh in this topic but I think that you
could have gone even broader with this
as you know for several years we have
been debating and arguing also against
um excessive usage of pesticides um and
we need to you know consume high quality
chemicals free food if we want to
increase health of of our citizens so if
I just circle back although I completely
agree that we need to put more focus on
health when making climate related
policies I still believe that if even if
we don't explicitly say so it's
something that comes out as a byproduct
you know anyway um because every
successfully implemented climate policy
will inevitably have positive health
benefits uh healthier environment means
healthier people it's you know that that
simple um I have taken note of what you
said and also of what you wrote in your
report and you know in my continuous
efforts to improve healthc care
throughout Europe I will do out most for
it to be included also in further
legislations thank you thank you very
muchena thank you very much Arena and
our last speaker in this round is Malta
gal and you have the minute for have two
minutes for uh uh speaking on stop food
waste in the EU helping the most
vulnerable please Malta you have the
floor thank you very much and I have to
admit I totally agree with that idea
that we have to oblige the supermarkets
and the the restaurants to give away to
donate their food but as it is in the
current state like people that try to
save the food from supermarkets for
example in Germany where I'm from they
are punished for this they're brought to
court uh for saving food out of the the
bins and I think this is the first step
to make this a legal act and to
decriminalize it if people uh really
engage in Saving food and also yeah Pro
providing more more food uh food uh uh
accessibility to to everyone actually so
I think the main task should be to focus
on the big corporations on the
supermarkets because if we look at Food
waste um often food I think there's far
more food waste than what we uh talk
about because what is in the count
because the supermarkets they say okay
no this this carrot looks ugly I don't
buy it and I think this is already where
we should start where we should make
sure that all the uh the the food that
is produced and that is eatable that
does not poison anybody that we make
sure that this food also comes to
somebody who can who can eat it at a
later point and by this we of course
would have far more food on the market
in the very first place so um currently
actually we're working on a legislation
to reduce the food waste uh we want to
to try to uh also put a reduction
targets for uh the production uh phase
and also for the processing phase and so
on um so we are on it we're not uh as uh
motivated or the commission proposal is
not as strong as we expected it we
wanted to stick to 50% reduction until
uh 2030 to stick to uh our sdgs as uh we
uh have it there um we will fight for it
in the next month so let's see how far
we get thank
you
thank you very much and just allow me to
say one sentence I would be happy if
some regulations we made on the European
level that hinder industry to use these
products for production uh would also be
uh eliminated because we are sometimes
making our problems ourselves uh but we
can talk about that perhaps later um now
uh we come to the um feedback of our
ideas boosters on both topics and I
first like to give the floor to Adrian
cosin
pop so thank you very much for your
answers I'm happy that you you're taking
note of everything that we're saying and
proposing and you're working actively on
that but on a different note uh than uh
the health issue related to climate
change is that I personally think Europe
has the potential to reach Net Zero by
2050 through Innovation but what we
really need to do in the next decades is
is to establish strategic Partnerships
with all the other major polluters all
around the world because even if we take
all the carbon emissions in Europe uh
there's still going to be decades until
our own people um can uh can benefit
from this uh so uh to achieve that I
think Europe needs to lead the way to
Net Zero and it needs to have a strong
position in regard to phasing out fossil
fuels urgently at cop 28 and this should
be done uh with no longer wait because
the health of our CI citizens can can
wait no longer thank
you thank you very much and now I give
the pl floor to aror Charles
B thank you again I completely agree
with everything uh you said while I was
reading and preparing this speech this
was exactly what I had in mind only in
one minute it was a bit shorter um
indeed uh we have come used to such
perfect apples in the store uh
unfortunately businesses will always
want more profit that's how businesses
work um we need to as Citizens convince
each other that the apple with like the
small speckle on it is also eatable and
perfectly delicious uh so I think that's
something that we all uh are into
together and as I pointed out in my
speech this is a collaboration it's not
only big corporations it's also us as
active citizens that uh needs to to work
on this and I believe that we can uh
later on we have the Beautiful Workshop
feel free all to uh to join us where we
will work out a concrete plan to do this
in a local level and hopefully we can uh
expand so I'm looking forward for the
future thank
you thank you very much and uh I think
uh I have to say thank you to all of our
speakers and their turn now to the last
round of the ideas to talk about death
information and AI so um first
is I'll we have to change first thank
you first is Miss Mrs me ptin it's right
me ptin but it was close ptin and I will
tell she will tell us it is important to
add disinformation warnings as a default
on all news sites unless they share all
their sources for of information and the
floor is yours thank you disinformation
is a serious threat to democracy and
Trust in the media and it is especially
harmful to young people who are more
likely to be exposed to it and less
likely to be able to identify it that is
why we propose to require all new sites
to add disinformation warnings by
default unless they State all the
information sources this would make it
easier for people to identify and also
avoid unreliable new sources while uh
there is no existing EU legislation that
proposes a similar initiative
there are for example the proposed media
Freedom Act and Digital Services act
which both aim to address this
information in different ways however
neither act goes as far to as stipulate
that this information warnings should be
visible on the news site this is why
implementing this regulation would be a
necessary step to ensure ensure that all
Europeans have the access to Reliable
information thank
you
thank you very much for this very
inspiring input and now I give the floor
to uh CLA Sophie pic uh as she has an
idea on how to support for Innovative
projects in the field of artificial
intelligence please the floor is yours
thank you artificial intelligence as
different as the narrative surrounding
the consequences of AI on the labor
market and democracy may be they are
united by an certainty for a future
shaped by AI with the ambitious AI act
come new challenges which if we are to
set Global standards will require the
necessary financial support for research
therefore I a computer science student
myself represent the proposal for
Innovative for more programs to promote
the development of innovative projects
in the field of artificial intelligence
by providing grants and other support to
universities and research institutions
as well as artists and media projects
These funds make it possible to enable
interdisciplinary research in particular
particular not detached from computer
science but with computer scientists so
that we can find an ethical and
sustainable approach to AI as a
society thank you very much and I would
like to turn to our members of the
parliament again and first I give the
floor to me m pazar Tunda that's
right thank you very much I
am very happy to hear about this
measure on thisinformation warnings as a
default on all news sites unless they
share the same sources of
information we thought about it as well
but it didn't go through and um we
struggled but we had a very similar
idea
so the media Freedom Act is currently
being
negotiated
between member states and the Parliament
and we need several outcomes from this
negotiation
transparency on the first first place
and also we need to identify what is
fake and what is not and this will help
us
tremendously and it will help you the
youth because let's be honest this
information has been around forever
but because we are connected to our
phones and we can all access this
information and assimilated this is new
to
us and we are all aware of how important
it is to to use these devices and
information properly therefore we need
to include that
dimension in all discussions with member
states when I was your age more or less
that's and it's been a while I was very
lucky
because where I
studied we learned about
aristotles and since
then well now we can see smartphones and
AI but aralis as a
link is linked to this because
against the current
situation the Aristotle's thoughts will
help us identify what is fake and what
is not and that's been very helpful for
me throughout the years so maybe that's
an advice I would like to share with you
all thank you very
much is M Lara Ferrara for two minutes
again on adding disinformation warnings
as a def fall on all new sites please
yeah thank you very much thank you very
much it was a great pleasure for me to
be with you in Strasburg and uh it's
again a great pleasure for me to be here
in Brussels with you hearing your
um ideas and your proposals uh indeed I
appreciate a lot um your proposal to add
warnings on um uh websites um that talks
about uh news um as might said before we
worked a lot about that in the in the
special committee um and um uh a part of
this uh political experience I am a
lawyer so it's like like a a
um a way of uh thinking uh when we talk
about uh thisinformation I mean the
first thing that we should need is a
judical uh definition of what is his uh
thisinformation
and uh what I realized uh during The
Works uh done in uh in the committee and
also during the Parliamentary
missions uh still now we don't have uh
judical definition of what is um this
information and this is of utmost
importance because um if we have a
judical um definition of what is this
information uh we should recognize when
to act who could act and how to act to
prevent this information so uh a
proposal like uh the one that you uh
made is very important because it's like
an academical approach
um indicating the sources um uh you are
able to understand better uh the truth
or the lies and um to to get a better
knowledge so uh thank you very much and
when uh you you you will reply uh I'm
curious to yeah to to know better what
do you think about the possibility to
have uh at least uh some criteria to
have definition of uh thisinformation
thank you very
much thank you very much and finally I
would like to welcome
MBA and she wants to speak on both
topics on Innovative projects in the
field of artificial intelligence and on
thisinformation warnings as a default on
all news sites but also for two
minutes okay thank you very
much
thank you thank you very much thank you
for giving me this
opportunity we not often get to exchange
our views
with young Europeans so thank you very
much and thank you for the Dynamics of
the meeting because yes it's very fast
and we only have one minute uh but
that's the case as well in the
Parliament and this is well enough to
talk about these ideas so
um thank you for organizing this meeting
I think that we should do it more
often we've said
it AI is a key factor in our daily
lives it's a key factor for Citizens
politics institutions
and it's drawing a lot of um attention
so we do
need uh an artificial intelligence act
and this is a tricky one because as my
colleague said what is uh this
information what is good information so
we are working
on a reg regulatory framework on all
these Concepts and it's very tricky
because it's difficult to to regulate
Freedom as well especially because we
are dealing here with almost um
philosophical Concepts but we need to
regulate uh these Concepts and this is
happening already with the media Freedom
Act and we need to know who is providing
the information right uh who is writing
these articles what media
who is
funding that piece of
information we are facing a huge
challenge but with this media Freedom
Act with this act on artificial
intelligence we are working on it and
we're working on this regulatory
framework thank you very
much thank you very much Tiana and now I
would give the floor back to our two
young people our idea boosters first
mikia you have the
floor yeah so uh thanks a lot for your
inputs uh first of all I am very happy
to hear that you know young Europeans
are on the same level as you know
members of the European Union and we are
let's say discussing uh similar kind of
actions toward uh fighting
thisinformation and to be fair when I
was listening to your comments that was
one of the first things which kind of
came to my head that actually I guess we
have now came to The Next Step which
should be done to fight the
disinformation would be then actually to
kind of for formally kind of put this uh
understanding behind what is this
information so we can move forward
because we have to understand that
obviously what as we have seen in the
past years propaganda and overall
disinformation is you
know becoming larger and larger thread
for us and especially in these fragile
times we are living now it would be more
important to stand up for the truth so
that's why we'll be looking forward to
see how this develops uh in the future
thank
[Music]
you thank you very much and last but not
least CLA Sophia Pik you have the floor
um I want to use this last minute not
only to stress that we are talking about
applications like Chet GPT if we are
talking about AI we are also talking
about the impact it has on the climate
about the energy consumption about the
water consumption about the hardware
behind it how it changes our definition
of knowledge how we create knowledge um
where the data is coming from and also
who labels the data under which working
conditions so I just want to urge you to
always also look at this side of this
topic and not only about like I don't
know the fun part about how impressive
AI can be if we talk look at
applications like chbt for
example
thank you very
much I think that was a very important
input uh especially also when it comes
to the multiple layers of uh challenges
and chances that lie in the AI and uh so
I think I'm looking forward also to
further exchanges uh with all of you
because you raised a lot of very
important topics today and now I would
like to introduce to you
um our um
uh our our vice president of the
European Parliament Mrs P Pinero uh she
is responsible for the I event and uh
yeah Mrs Pino you have the floor for
three minutes for a final statement on
the summaries and the discussions thank
you for being here today with us
[Music]
thanks thank you thank you Sab M laa
Nara
with all of you they animated this
debate so thank you very much for
listening to the suggestions the idea
that came H and uh particular thank you
to all of you young girls and boys
because you shared your ideas with
passion uh the ideas collected in the uh
I report I 2023 I I had the privilege
and that's exactly what it is I had the
privilege to listen to your voice in
June during the
event we had in Strasburg we uh
discussed together uh the different
topics and we listen to you to your
stories and uh I saw through your
eyes the heart of Europe beating and I'm
very glad to see that that you know
moment of
sharing
uh didn't stop there and thanks to the
members of parliament for the whole
Parliament staff so this exchange this
sharing is going to be uh transformed
into some something practical and all of
you are invited to become the
ambassadors of the ideas that we shared
that we discussed over the last
months you have to propose projects to
uh help us in turning this project into
realities so as you know the uh European
elections are around the corner so your
contribution your ideas and in
particular the participation of all
young Europeans is going to be
fundamental to make this election a
success and I think that your ideas
today are a huge source of commitment uh
you know from foreign policy or the
self-sufficient of raw materials so the
fact of having paid train ship Erasmus
Plus a greater education on
sustainability climate change or uh food
waste and uh artificial intelligence or
uh disinformation warnings all these
topics are
crucial
and they must be turned into real topics
of
debate in view of the public European
debate for the elections because
it's your priorities must be at the core
of the debate because Europe always
represented this you know future the
need for a greater and a better future
that we can reach through a joint work
and future is you you represented it
today as well your ideas the ideas you
support and share and
so I'm very happy because all the
suggestions you share today are not just
linked to you know
youth
politics uh for a sake of time I would
like to mention just one remark that I
really Embrace so the need for a a
common EU foreign policy one of the most
important reform that we need we need to
be stronger together we need to speak
with just one voice so
that we can uh you know
be and to we can speak with just one
voice with the rest of the world so uh
we need to uh Foster a common foreign
policy otherwise we won't be a political
body that's uh something fundamental in
order to strengthen our Union so if we
want to meet uh the needs if we want to
reply to the concerns of young voters uh
we have to listen to what young people
are saying when they are Marching on the
streets uh when they uh publish their
opinions
online and of course on what they said
on the youth idea report that's why this
hearing is a a very important tool for
the parliament for all of us
because there's no doubt when young
people feel they are
heard then they have the opportunity to
committed to take part with a great
involvement to the political process by
interacting in an open way we can
inspire a new generation of Voters who
are going to shape uh the future of our
continent and who can promote a more
inclusive democ Cy where every single
voice can find its
own
space so I hope that all the uh young
people here today coming from the
different International Association they
can you know take home important
messages they can find
motivation to widespread this ideas
everywhere through every mean and to
come
contribute to transform them into
something
real into a you know peace of future as
we
said
because the most you know um Visionary
ideas some Utopias as
well because these ideas are the ones
who created the revolution of the past
Century never forget that you know
people who wrote in venten the
manifesto who was the which was the
pillar for uh the European construction
they were young people at that time and
they were in an island in that Island
because they Freedom
was limited due to a horrible
dictatorship and through that condition
they kept on looking you know forward
even if fascism you know was uh removing
their
freedom
so young people never forget that young
people were animating the future of our
uh continent in in Maan Square in Europe
in Kiev which was not so focused they
were manifesting for Europe with the
flags on the shoulders and due to that
many young people
died in that square so the memory of
revolutions you know brought along by
young girls young European boys so we
need to listen to your
voices with uh the utmost care so I'm
here to say to State clearly that we
stand with you we are here we listen to
All of you with great attention and we
are ready to follow this pathway that
sometimes seems you know maybe uh more
challenging sometimes seems blocked but
we are ready to build with all of you
the Europe of the
future the
one placing at the center of our
commitment Young Generation so thank you
thank you all for your Daily Commitment
and for your partic ation today thank
you thank you very much vice president
dear Pina for the strong statement for
young people and uh I now would like to
give the floor at least uh to uh Cruz
again for um a final statement
representing all uh of the idea boosters
today please you have the floor firstly
on behalf of all of us I would like to
say thank you thank you for welcoming us
to the European Parliament we are glad
to have so many of you in the room today
thank you to the member of the European
Parliament for listening asking
questions and providing input your
attendance is greatly appreciated it
demonstrates the importance of Youth
perspectives and ideas and shows that
this Parliament is paying attention to
what young people want and have to say
it has been exciting to present the most
ideas from the youth ideas report coming
from eye
2023 you have listened to 10 of us today
stepping in as ambassadors for these
ideas but we want to highlight that this
is the culmination of many young
people's efforts who have contributed to
the process over the last few months the
European youth hearing is one important
step to take the voices of young people
seriously but this process needs to
continue we hope that the
ideas we hope that the ideas we
presented to you today will keep being
discussed and that you will take
inspiration from our exchanges today and
that you will take these ideas forward
in your legislative work on our side we
are committed to talking to these ideas
uh taking these ideas forward this
afternoon we will
lead 10 workshops with each of these
workshops aimed at developing the idea
further and 10 them into concrete
projects we want this process to
continue beyond today each one of us
will be working on implementing a
concrete project by Spring
2024 which we are planning to present
during the European youth week in 2024
in the parliament we are committed to
concrete actions that from these
proposals for us young people in the
room the European youth hearing is a
great reminder to keep pushing for the
change we want to see we need to keep
speaking up about the things we care
about we need to make our voices heard
pushing for the change we want to see
can take many forms it can be a project
it can be a petition it can be a
demonstration it can be as simple as
starting discussions with friends to
support our voices needs and concerns we
should actively partake in
decision-making process finally I want
to make a call to action to the youth
your vote in the 2024 European election
matters it ensures that we can
contribute to more relevant and
inclusive policies for our generations
and those to come we should actively
shape the European Union we want to live
in ensuring our concerns and
perspectives are heard and address thank
you thank you very much to all of you to
the young uh uh idea boosters to our
guests to the colleagues who took part
in the hearing this hearing has once
again brought us the proof that young
people are not only our future they are
actually very active uh developing ideas
and solutions and shaping our present
and giving us direction for the way
ahead and after listening to you I'm
convinced that you are indeed Beyond any
doubt our most valuable asset and source
for a new spirit and ideas not only are
you bringing fresh and new ideas and
approaches to the global challenges the
EU is facing but you also show a keen
commitment to working towards a more
sustainable Innovative and competitive
yet socially fate European project by
investing your energy your time and your
ideas uh your brains your activities uh
to this common European idea uh the
proficiency and determination which with
you bring your ideas to the policymaking
today makes us proud it also puts a lot
of responsibility on our shoulders and
that's clear uh that we should not have
here just a hearing for one day but
really work on on your ideas and what
you are doing here uh and uh I would
like to make a clear commitment as chair
of the cult committee the committee
responsible for youth policies in
general not only to listen to your ideas
but also to take you as close as
possible to the naturual decision-making
processes by mainstreaming youth
policies into all policy Fields what I'm
still missing even we organize such
hearings like today is that every
committee should do that because what
you have to tell us what you have to
inspire us to is not just for the cult
committee not just for the committee on
youth policy because you talk on Foreign
Affairs policy you have ideas on
sustainability and environmental
policies you have ideas on social
polities policies you have ideas on on
everything we are doing also uh when it
comes to to to raw materials uh external
policies or development policies you
have ideas to all fields of policy and
so for me it would be very important
that each and every committee does such
hearings and I hope that I will be one
day successful in pushing for this also
in the CCC that every committee invites
young people to their hearings to listen
to their ideas so that we really have a
stronger involvement in our actual and
everyday's policym of young people thank
you very much for engaging thank you
very much for bringing your ideas to the
Parliament and I hope that uh we will
have also in future fruitful cooperation
with the Young Generation and the
parliamentarians here in this house
because we are also representatives for
the Young Generation and uh that needs
uh that we have a structural and
sustainable Exchange on the European
parliament's level with the commission
and all institutions that are there
thank you very much and finally I would
like uh to invite you to be more active
also politically because uh in
Democratic systems real solution can all
only emerge through debate and
participation and you know that in the
next year on the 9th of June or also the
days before depending on the country
where you come from we will have again
European elections and in some countries
we have already the age of 16 where
young people can vote and I just can beg
you take part in this inform yourself uh
uh take a look to who is representing
you on the European level and take your
choice uh because if you don't take your
choice other will do that for you and
that might not be in in your sense so
I'm very happy uh to have such engaged
uh group of people today here and uh uh
now now at the end I would like to
invite you uh that uh all people who
want to attend uh one of the workshops
should now follow the EP staff who will
be at the door over there and direct you
to the uh meeting rooms where the
discussions in the Workshops can take
place thank you very much for being
[Applause]
here thank you for your engagement and I
hope uh that is just the start of a
fruitful Corporation thanks a lot for
sure thank
you